you typically bring people together but
you and your wife abby set off a
fierce online debate regarding
dishwashers yes
she is so controlling about the
dishwasher kelly sometimes
i load it and she will reload it when i
leave the room
so it's more organized i don't know what
people's problem is
about doing that i'm not sure well um
uh just to let you know i have found her
doppelganger and that is me i am abby
i am the one i'm like just stop
like i'll do it um but we have the video
that kicked this off it's awesome
this is a kerfuffle what are you talking
about
buddy this is not how you pack
the dishwasher it's gonna wash the sink
no
no no no here's the problem
when i redo this it wouldn't even need a
wash we could wait a whole day you know
what you
oh you're gonna redo this you are
unbelievably
dish controlling i don't know
um i saw that and i was like
i think disconcert i'm untamed
i it well something should be tamed is
what i'm saying because i saw that and i
was like oh my god and if there's food
on it i can't
like i don't think you need to like
watch it but like there's not tiny
people in the dishwasher like
scrubbing it for you you know so you
gotta do it i am
100 abby on this one so you have lost me
in this
um but i want to say it's nice though
that
to have a partner like in life that will
do the dishes with you i'll say that
yep i'm still here just waiting for you
to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever help